bienvenidos una vez más en el vídeo
pasado te había mostrado esta chinche
que se llama la serie geométrica tenemos
una cierta base a que pudo ser cualquier
número digamos un medio o 10 o lo que
sea pero la idea es ir elevando ese
número a exponentes naturales y luego
sumar todo esto de aquí es una serie
geométrica lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar una fórmula cerrada para la
suma de los elementos de una serie
geométrica entonces pues dada una base
ahí llegamos hasta cierto exponente n
hay aquí puse de menos 2 no no no aquí
debería de decir a la n ok aquí abajo
también debería de ser a la n eso me
pasa cuando me empiezo a apresurar en
mis vídeos bueno ni modo así pasa como
sea a ver entonces regresando a esto lo
que quiero hacer es definir ese como
esta suma geométrica y lo que quiero
hacer es definir otra suma para hacer un
truco y encontrar el valor de ese
entonces en lo que me voy a fijar es en
a x
sale eso de ahí es igual a pues eso
simplemente es a por esta suma de aquí
entonces vamos a ver qué le sucede si
empezamos a distribuir a es la misma
verdad entonces si comenzamos a
distribuir a cuánto nos quedaría a ver a
por a la 0 es dejar mejor escribirlo voy
a hacerlo paso a paso nos quedaría a por
al acero más a por a la 1 más a por al
cuadrado más patata más a por a la n-1
más a por a a la m ok entonces
simplemente tomé la a y la distribuye en
toda esta suma de aquí listo vamos a
hacer esto igual a vamos a multiplicar
esto nos queda apurada la cero es a la 1
luego hay que hacer a por a la 1 que
está cuadrada luego nos queda a kubica
luego más trata está más a ala en verdad
porque aquí simplemente sumamos los
exponentes más a la n 1 ok entonces esto
de aquí es a por él
pero déjame hacerte una pregunta bueno
primero déjame copiar ese entonces voy a
poner ese aquí para que veas que quiero
hacer entonces esa es la suma original y
es a la 0 + a la 1 más al cuadrado más
al jugo y así sucesivamente hasta llegar
a más a la n bueno entonces ahora si va
la pregunta clave qué sucede cuando
restamos estas dos expresiones es decir
qué pasa si hago a s - s déjame poner
por aquí un signo menos a ver voy a
hacer a ese menos ese va entonces aquí
la s le estoy restando estoy restando
sda ese y del lado derecho que sucede
pues a ver todos estos términos les
aparece un signo menos lo voy a poner
con color rosa - - - todos estos de aquí
son menos entonces que sucede pues a ver
esto se cancela esto de aquí también se
cancela al cubo también se cancela y
también a la n se cancela porque tenemos
sus versiones positivas y negativas nada
nos queda menos a la 0 verdad tenemos
este término de aquí y luego hay que
sumar hay que sumar a la n 1 ok pues a
la cero simplemente es uno que obtenemos
pues obtenemos que
por efe - efe es igual a aa la n 1
-1 ok déjame factorizar un s de la
izquierda entonces tenemos ese porque a
menos uno es igual a aa la n
1 - 1
ok
que tenemos después pues podemos dividir
ambos lados por a menos uno déjame
borrar un poquito de esta con estas
cosas que tengo aquí arriba a ver voy a
borrar pues creo que de aquí hacia
arriba no hay problema verdad entonces
deja elaborar esto de aquí hay no change
in eso eso está borrando algo que no
quiero mejor borró desde acá sí hallada
ahí está estas otras cositas de por aquí
listo ya tenemos un poco más de espacio
entonces tenemos
así estábamos en esto dividiendo a ambos
lados de la ecuación entre a menos 1
obtenemos que ese es igual a aa la n más
uno menos uno dividido entre a menos uno
muy bien entonces qué es lo que esto nos
dice ya definimos una serie geométrica
es igual a la suma desde acá igual a
cero hasta n de a al acá y ya logramos
encontrar una fórmula cerrada para eso
está fórmula nos quedó igual a aa la n-1
menos uno dividido entre a menos uno muy
bien porque esto de aquí es útil pues
bueno ahora tenemos una forma de sumar
potencias fácilmente por ejemplo qué
pasa si me pregunto por voy a borrar
aquí abajo para hacer un ejemplo
entonces qué sucede si me pregunto por
digamos la suma de las potencias de 3
empezando desde 1 déjame escribirlo
vamos a poner la suma desde 3
a la 0 + 3 a la 1 3 al cuadrado y así
hasta digamos 3 a la 10
ok esto de aquí es igual a la suma desde
acá igual a cero hasta n de no perdón
hasta 10 porque en ellas 10 de 3 a la k
va entonces esta fórmula que acabamos de
encontrar pues aquí a es igual a 3 en es
igual a 10 entonces la suma simplemente
es igual a 3 elevado a la 11 menos 1 y
eso de ahí dividido entre a menos 13
menos 1 y eso es igual a pues podemos
simplificar un poquito 3 a la 11 menos 1
dividido entre 2 listo estoy aquí es más
o menos útil verdad eso es ya es un
número específico y bueno tenemos que
sacar cuánto estrés a la 11 pero bueno
más o menos es la idea verdad esto es
especialmente útil si tenemos que es una
potencia de 10 o bien que es 10 pero
bueno lo que quiero hacer ahorita es
tomar esto y preguntarnos qué sucede
cuando n se va a infinito deja de
mostrarte eso
y entonces qué sucede hay dos tipos de
series y no quiero borrar con amarillo
dejan a borrar con negro entonces hay
dos tipos de series de las cuales
podemos tomar su suma hay series finitas
y series infinitas para que al sumar
todos los términos de una serie infinita
obtengamos una constante y no infinito
lo que tenemos que pedir es que esta
serie converja ahora si lo piensas
tantito para que una suma infinita
converja cada número debe de volverse
más y más y más chiquito conforme nos
vamos a infinito entonces vamos a hacer
el ejemplo con un número más chiquito
que uno digamos a igual a un medio que
nos quedaría con una serie geométrica
infinita entonces tendríamos digamos la
suma geométrica desde acá igual a cero
hasta infinito wow esto de aquí va a
quedar bonito verdad vamos a tener una
suma ya que tiene una infinidad de
sumandos y vamos a ver que de hecho
vamos a obtener una cosa que es finita
entonces aunque sumemos una infinidad de
números vamos a llegar a algo que es
finito eso de ellas sorprendente pero
bueno
es un medio y esa la vamos a ir
aumentando a las potencias acá entonces
es uno más un medio luego más un cuarto
más un medio al jugo que es un octavo
más un dieciseisavo más y así
sucesivamente cada término se va
haciendo más y más pequeño fíjate que
cada uno es la mitad del anterior pero
ahora qué sucede si aquí no tuviéramos
infinitos sino si fuera una n entonces
si fuera una n llegaríamos hasta más 1
entre 2 a la n verdad 1 entre 2 a la en
es lo mismo que un medio a la n pero si
nos vamos a nuestra fórmula entonces
obtendríamos que eso es igual a un medio
a la n-1 menos 1 y eso dividido entre un
medio menos uno y eso que nos da pues
antes de hacer eso pues ahí ya tenemos
una respuesta para una n fija pero
queremos ver qué pasa qué pasa con esta
expresión o sea cuál es el límite de
cuando n tiende a infinito de esta
expresión d
a la n 1 - 1 dividido entre un medio
menos 1 puedes saber todo esto de aquí
es constante pero qué le sucede a este
término cuando n se va infinito pues
cuanto es un medio a la infinito cuando
por así decirlo pues eso simplemente 0
verdad es un número superó un medio a la
3 mil millones pues es súper chiquito y
entonces eso de ahí queda 0 entonces lo
único que nos queda es menos 1 dividido
entre un medio menos 1 y podemos cambiar
los signos en el numerador y en el
denominador y nos queda un medio entre 1
menos un medio que es lo mismo que uno
entre un medio y uno entre un medio es 2
eso está sorprendente si tengo uno más
un medio más un cuarto más un octavo más
un dieciseisavo y así seguimos sumando y
sumando y sumando hasta tener una
infinidad de términos
entonces acabamos teniendo un numero
supersuperviolenta suma es 2 ok esto
está muy padre algo que está todavía más
padre es intentar darle una
interpretación a nuestra suma por
ejemplo podemos pensarlo como la suma de
las rebanadas de un país
insisto sumar una infinidad de términos
y que nos quede algo finito es
sorprendente se me acabó el tiempo nos
vemos hasta la próxima